i'd like to start with an observation
about recent crises
because whether it's the cost of living
crisis as rachel has said
or recovering from the pandemic
our economy is weaker than our
competitors
less resilient
brittle
and ultimately we're all poorer for it
that's why i'm clear
labor will fight the next election on
economic growth
there is no task more central to my
ambitions for britain than making the
country and its people better off
now
tonight i think you'll hear two other
candidates for prime minister who'll
also define the choice for their party
to be about the economy and about growth
but what a choice it is
in one corner you have rishi sunak the
architect of the cost of living crisis
in the other you have liz trust
the latest graduate from the school of
magic monetary economics
neither of them has the answers to the
economic challenges that we face
and who can be surprised
under their watch the average british
family is 8
800 pounds poorer than their equivalents
in advanced economies
now that's not just a failure of policy
it's a failure of philosophy
and their leadership contest is not
going to change that
because both rishi sooner can list trust
rage against the dying of the
thatcherite light
they don't understand
economic strength in the 21st century
needs partnership
they don't believe you need state and
market
business and worker
the everyday economy and the
technological frontier
all contributing together
if you want strong secure
and fair growth
i'm under no such illusions
thank you
rebooting our economy
is the way we will define our task in
government
and it will ask searching questions of
my party and our instincts
we can't be like the tories clinging to
the old ideas
trapped in our history
to give britain the fresh start it needs
we need a new approach
my goal
is straightforward
to maximize the contribution we all make
to national prosperity
every business
every person
every community
now it sounds simple but in reality
we've failed to do this for decades
the best of british business is the best
in the world
but we've geared our whole economy to
delivering only for those firms
and we've been complacent about the
number of jobs created which are low pay
and insecure
when insecurity stops people getting on
and too few communities feel the benefit
of the wealth that we create
which makes people feel that hard work
is not rewarded
now
in a nutshell we draw our economic
strength from too few places
and like a skyscraper built without
foundations that ultimately leaves us
weak
and if you want evidence of this
look no further than the cost of living
crisis
everywhere i go
i hear the same stories
people scared about the future
worried that when winter comes they'll
face horrible choices about what to
spend their money on
pensioners
who can't afford to turn on the heating
families cutting back on what they buy
their children
but there's one thing i hear
time and time again
that worries me more than anything else
and that is working people telling me
hard work
doesn't pay
that they're working harder and harder
just to stand still
now that alarms me for two reasons
first because i've been lucky enough to
take a journey in my life
from a working-class family to head of
the crown prosecution service and my
fear is an economy so racked by low
growth and insecurity means people from
my background can't get on
second
because
honestly
what does it say about the state of
britain when working people feel that
hard work doesn't pay
what does it say about the health of our
country
the health even
of our democracy
it says an unwritten contract is broken
a contract that says in return for hard
work you get a fair reward
that you don't have to feel insecure
about your prospects
that your contribution
is respected
it's a two-way thing
a strong national economy needs everyone
making the best contribution that they
can whatever their circumstances
wherever they live
but in exchange we must make sure the
contribution working people make to that
national effort is fairly rewarded that
hard work does pay
that their effort
is respected
that they enjoy the security they need
to get on
to do all that
we need three things
growth
growth
growth